dinner that's my wedding song oh I got
my Wolverine Gregg claws I changed my
pens is your infected hands we're gonna
watching the cosmic wonder marvel x-men
Disney Plus announcement guys great
ought to get in the lowdown on some
awesome info that is necessary to get if
you guys didn't see it we did a collab
with the cosmic wonder where we talked
about her Wolverine fan casting that is
over on his channel and then we are
doing a collab this week talking about
fantastic for Fantastic cast a go to our
community page there should be a pull up
right now so go over there go vote leave
your comments as well and we are gonna
be shooting with war from the cosmic
Wonder I believe tomorrow and we should
have a video by this weekend so keep a
lookout for that
in the meantime subscribe to cosmic
Wonder and let's watch whatever this
announcement is everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel where we talk
about all things Marvel and of course
everything relating to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe unfortunately it's
been a pretty rough time due to the
coronavirus a lot of movies have why did
you say that films and TV shows at
Marvel Studios has been halted as well
but in the midst of all this bad news we
have gotten some good news venom 2 is
still on track for its October 2nd -
release date and marvel it's got a
planning on releasing Black Widow in
theaters and just last night Disney Plus
has teased us with some x-men news now
there's a lot that comes with this x-men
news and I'm going to break down every
single thing that we know about it and
the more we find out the more I'll
update you on so be sure to subscribe
and notifications turned on so you don't
miss out on anything
so last night many people noticed that
Disney Plus has added many different
x-men icon images to it now is knee plus
already has a lot of animated Marvel
shows on I mean just some every
spider-man Fantastic Four at the Silver
Surfer etc so at first glance many
people didn't really think too much
about this but since then several hours
have passed by and overnight
sites are reporting that there may be
more to this that meets the eye
specifically MC of cosmic comm has
reported in an article on the site
stating that they have learned that
there is something related to the x-men
in the works now there are a lot of
things that they see but there are some
things that we can rule out considering
the fact that these icons are the 90s
versions of the x-men it's probably not
going to be something like the new
mutants that's probably not going to be
released on Disney Plus now of course
there is a possibility that there could
be a Marvel Studios x-men show coming to
Disney Plus I recall we found out that
Disney and Marvel Studios are working on
two disney plushies that we don't know
about yet and they're keeping it well
under wraps so there is a possibility
but it's still not likely it's most
likely further out and since we are
seeing these icons on Disney Plus now
that's most likely not the case however
the great news is for x-men fans is that
we are probably going to be getting a
revival of the original 90s x-men
serially new episodes coming to Disney
Plus now not too long ago the porters of
the original 90s x-men series said that
they were going to pitch a revival to
Disney and do we have to remember that
there is a little man over at Marvel and
Disney now Kevin Feige the president of
Marvel Studios is also now the CCO the
chief creative officer over Marvel
Studios as well
this means that he now has fulcrum only
we can't do that with them and the
animated series is what comes out on
Disney plus he's now in charge of all
television from Marvel and he's a huge
90s x-men fan so this is the most likely
scenario of what is going to be an
expensive luxury notice is just
absolutely incredible news to many of
the people here watching the nineties
x-men series now not only will we get to
live in the nostalgia of watching the
90s x-men animated series but we're
going to get new episodes and to get to
fall in love with the x-men all over
again super exciting news everybody let
me know in the comments down below did
you watch the x-men 90's animated show
whether you watched it in the 90's or
watched it later on let me know and let
me know how a little bit of both war and
revival for the show be sure to like the
video and subscribe
occasionally turned on to stay up to
date on everything relating to Marvel
and of course the MCU and so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or you 550 case
describer states and as always thank you
all so much for watching
look what what what you think that the
virus would make them stay home knows
guys it's outside blowing germs around
for Saul to breathe in and to ruin our
video that's right who needs good audio
alright guys we're gonna compensate for
the noise outside by talking exhume
early laughs the last time we reacted to
a cosmic wonder video we did discuss the
possibility of them maybe even doing a
live-action x-men show I don't think
they would ever do that and I didn't
even consider the possibility of them
potentially reviving the 90s animated
series and yes to answer the question I
did grow up watching the show I mean
spider-man x-men Batman the Animated
Series were like my main comic book
shows that I watched when I was a kid
and then x-men evolution around the time
the x-men live-action movie came
happening so there's like my main comic
book show jams growing up and actually I
don't know what made me do it but I
revisited the x-men animated series
before Disney Plus I bought season one
off of Amazon and I was surprised to see
how thought-provoking and deep it still
is because I would always hear that but
I rewatched the first season again last
year and I was like wow this is I didn't
all this like deep meaning stuff like
'we flew over my head and i was younger
like i did not catch on to how heavy
they were on the themes and allegories
that it really is front and center for
so much of the show it's not just
something that's in there is a nice
little nugget in the backdrop like it is
about those things and so I think that
actually yeah to revive it you would
have to probably do some animation
polish and whatever I mean I would still
want to remain hand-drawn not become
like this computer animated show or even
like a computer anime that looks
hand-drawn I want it to be like that
traditional looking like a comic book
come to life but not motion comic I'm
really not a big fan there's actually
kind of jarring for me to watch but the
idea of them bringing it back to life I
think that the show still has so much
love
I'm constantly hearing the question of
what was better x-men animated series or
Batman the Animated Series and I think
they're two very wildly different types
of shows but I think either one of those
series if you brought any of them back I
think fans would be very happy about it
and I think they could still work for
modern day and the 90s show was probably
the best adaptation of x-men ever done
so I'd absolutely love for them to do
that and I think that the viewership
perhaps inclined them on this
decision-making because they did put it
on Disney plus along with spider-man and
I think a lot of people when they got
Disney plus I've been reaching it there
something might have made them go we
should revive it here the way how
Netflix has revived some shows maybe
they're using this as an opportunity to
revive some like animated series which I
they would be frickin awesome they
should do in spider-man 2 why not give a
shot yeah I think that would be amazing
I'm actually kind of surprised that this
hasn't happened sooner but it also seems
like a really wonderful idea because
when I think of some of the most
quintessential moving visual comic book
adaptations I think of Batman the
Animated Series and x-men the animated
series for just that reason it's like
they're perfect in a sense that they are
able to reach the youth audience they're
super fun you grew up on them you loved
watching them but then yeah you can go
back and you can see the actual themes
and the stories at work and so I feel
like those were a really special product
of the mid to late 90s that I think
really could do what to come back
because again you'll have the double
audience of kids who want to see the
cartoons older folks who have the
nostalgia but who are also going to come
in and appreciate those and yeah I mean
as far as like some of the most
successful adaptations of these things
go people always point to x-men
spider-man or Batman the Animated Series
and so I am in love with this
information personally it seems perfect
and especially at a time more like DC
even still is kind of distinguished for
their animated films it would be cool to
see Marvel kind of bring it back to the
heyday of the series oh yeah absolutely
and since they are doing like those solo
based series like she-hulk and Moon
Knight miss Marvel Falcon Winter Soldier
all that we've talked about possibly
doing like focusing on as a specific
mutant for live-action show I think it
would be real complimentary actually to
have kind of both shows I don't think
ninety show nice isn't necessarily
become this cannon that ties into the
MCU but it's such a beloved series and I
think that would keep me subscribed
because lately I've been reading which
apps I should temporarily get rid of
because we going on I didn't yeah I mean
like maybe I'll just hold off on Disney
Plus for a little while and alluri yeah
I'm close to there I'll revive it finish
up Clone Wars so I've been like debating
which absolutely go but then I have been
watching some Disney movies lately you
know there's like some unfinished
stories on the show as well but on the
flip side if they are just planning on
starting up a new x-men animated series
something that's not a continuation of
the 90s show I feel like they can prod
you a good I've never been as excited if
I'm being totally transparent yeah but I
think with Disney plus they would want
to make sure it's something that is a
special or perhaps get the people who
were involved in the 90 show the writers
are the creators of that involvement in
a new series instead of like remaking it
but somehow tying in an even if it's
with people who were involved in that
show into a brand new series I think
it'd still be effective yes something
that really takes that tone and visual
look and everything something that
really feels akin to that and doesn't
feel like some kind of if it was some
kind of virtually revamp like 3d
animation show I might be a little bit
like lunch feelers turn alright I know
as opposed to yeah if they really go
with the classic hand-drawn style I mean
it would be cool to see some of those
old dangling storylines wrapped up but I
think just having that format come back
is the most important part alright guys
well did you go up in the x-men 90's
animated series do you want them to
revive you do you want the dude and you
showed you what a live action show
answer any freaking question you want
subscribe to cosmic Wonder keep a look
out for our video check out that
community post subscribe to the real
rejects click the notification bell and
hey we will catch you guys on the flip
flip flip